[Risadas]
andré marins alberto ii santa
[Música]
o sni com sua incrível é mais forte e é
precisamente assim que brincava com
tinha nove anos ainda tem nove anos indo
bem que sim e ela fica pelé fica pessoal
de quem fala andar que seja muito menos
é mais um nome como vocês puderam ler
pelo título hoje o brincar com o boni e
situações me perguntam tardar que já não
há mais desculpas a qualquer pessoa pode
não reunir o pessoal do blog não morreu
ou continua cá em casa e acha se você
inscrição em seu blog
ambos poderiam ver tantas histórias que
eu faço o que eu faço imensa história se
faz uma história com o bólido comigo
mesmo
então se você não seguir integrando
silva também roubar que enfrentam com
muita gente está aqui no canal numa
companhia em seu blog hoje vou fazer unb
é brincar com o blog como é que um
rostinho no concreto
mexes pessoal tudo que conseguiu
incrível não é atoa que continua
incrível pronunciará em breve nós dois
daí a aposta atenção dia 28 de junho vai
ser entregue 12 no cinema então
pretendia 28 vocês já podem ver o filme
toca aí porque costumo falar do crédito
nos dois porque é um dos meus favoritos
só pra ter uma noção financeiro em 2004
primeiro incrédulo já nessa altura eu
ganho um óscar de melhor animação
imaginem agora incluída nos dois e vai
ser muito bom nesse grande nos dois vão
conhecer novas personagens que eu vou
explicar agora carro teve que explicar a
história é essa por nossos vivem como é
que a mulher elástica vai ser chamada
por uma missão uma missão muito
complicada enquanto isso incrível vai
estar em casa levaram isso enquanto
mulher elástico placar
enquanto isso assim o internauta lavar
prato como também tiveram um bebê e
escrever têm força defensiva e tem
poderes que ninguém sabe o que ela já
saiu um rádio
sabe eu não fui eu acho que é uma
personagem do buriti já para landu
parceria também vai também por ser um
vilão superpoderoso que vai tentar
combater o conjunto entregue aos não vai
ver uma batalha gigante mas vejo um
filme para se ver quem ganha
mas só espero que vocês gostem do filme
em baixo vou deixar um link para o
treino do incrédulo os dois portanto
passei lá veja o trailer do primeiro não
se gostam eu tenho quase a certeza
cantar mas vai lá e cometem também mas
qual é o vosso estádio bonito é um
jackson flecha serve williams em mulher
elástica set efe um incrível afirmou não
haver essa proteína vai mais além do im
e agora senhor incrível mas não deixar
michael jordan é a estrela rock bola até
que está nossa criatura pessoal estava
no meio do gelo linha como ela mal samba
que espera falar em sonho que eu tinha
que premiou ontem muita comida nenhum
para ter um novo inimigo pela voz do
banco navegação deus
agora nós é como eu gosto de comida
como vocês podem ver onde ficou muito
fluída e eu normalmente costuma comer
phenom é o que eu lhe dou mais vezes
neste dia 5 e por duas vezes por semana
três meses eu costumo dar fruta e
coisinhas que gosta mais só eu tenho é
que como o milho uva e massa dura que
passa por fazer não sei porquê mas ela
adora brincar essa massa mas eu não lhe
posso estar muito porque não estragar
eta é tipo como vocês comecem sempre bem
toda a semana inteira vão engordar é um
só a montar um circo ai meu deus mas não
pode voltar a comida acabou eu acho
porque de uma uva bole a alma não há
quem não vai derrubar boyle pela uva
o disco está há pouco tempo mas eu adoro
uvas e acho que é feita sobretudo
e se eu fugir pode se observar e ver se
eu fosse embora e deixa fugir agora meus
lindos lindos pequenino altura até o
cacho de uva mesmo e agora já acabou e
ela é tão inteligente ou vai los a
buscar mais eu sabe que há mais comida
pois muita gente glory deixam fazer o
melhor e não lindo não vai mudar mais
nada não vai fugir do guarani acabou
fugindo vários acabou ferindo a taxas
bem isso
podcasts nisso não na câmara não pode
também tem muito cara morre pessoal acha
que é brincadeira agora quando é um pelo
iefp é porque brincar
entretanto chegou nilson olha eu sou
tentado fazer é cuidar agora está com
ciúme a cantar com 53 triunfos não olhem
uma taxa de 5 através do blog espaço a
bordo
agora é correr atrás de quem pode fugir
porque a senhora vai acompanhar pode
acompanhar logo ganhar a companheira
marina não não podem não entram já te
disse mori não hori melbourne
não bole bole bole as vendas o que o
talo qo não está possuído olhem só como
fluir
agora a moda é desculpa
então embora já não há mais comida já
não é mais crime viram como eu respondeu
nomes é uma coisa que eu gosto muito
também deu desde a primeira semana que
eu respondo um bode ou não termina com o
dinheiro como nunca uma difícil missão
muito fofo tão lindas mundo cada vez
mais fofo o pote 2 muito fiéis
a shantala da cunhada ai meu deus como
ressalta a contradição
olha que eu já está asfaltado já passou
de comida rápida porque as linhas é
comida portuguesa foi muito ocorre é que
o esforço em outra vez num mesmo sítio
ordem precisa acabar eu vou ganhar
ana maria também são muito bem treinados
a salvar e é só ligar nem sempre
escolhidas impossível ganhar molly 321
vai e por onde lá vai voltar e correr
vai poder mostrar o local estava com
quatro meses na al
não pode mais colocar ou não de modo a
que ele faça uma coisa uma palmadinha
aqui o meu lindo fala nem a palmadinha
palmadinha toma dinheiro bari
eu te amo e hei de morrer num embate
político
basicamente os meus amigos aqui na casa
há ainda vale vai cup porque tenho aqui
uma bola de basquete vamos ver se o blog
tem medo da bola
321 cuidar e não pensou que era um
inimigo não tá doido não está possuído
não informada pronto já seria o que isto
é uma roda gigante será que eu posso
comer a língua eu penso mesmo que era
comida foi embora foi bob vai correr
atrás
o que é isso não é comum com o mesmo
cuidado em não sair não pode e não pode
despertar e dos cientistas
eu acho que eu toco para comer e pedras
podem tucanos tudo o que é isso eu acho
que o manejo do lixo
meu deus eu estava possuído olha só o
que fazer com a bola
será que ela encontrou um tesouro aqui o
que se passa aqui alguma coisa
eu tenho qualquer coisa aqui mostra bem
o que eu disse é o destaque da porque
alguns modelos é preciso ter cuidado com
a simbólica o que está a passar o que
tem lá dentro o que tem aqui dentro onde
há qualquer coisa que me faz confusão é
outra vez
olha só o que é especial mas justificar
por que construir isso vocês quiserem
ver mais vídeos que o brincar com o bode
como tem muito em baixo desde há muito
lhe que neste vídeo é sério nós
conseguimos muito lá que vou trazer o
bode em breve por tanta pressa em se
apressa em isso não foi inscrito no
canal inscrevam se lavar pode correr
atrás de mim falou deus olhe
[Música]